[Music]
where the hell can i get eyes like that
greetings fellow film buffs i am naz
perez and welcome to an almost fresh and
exciting new episode of rt essentials
why almost fresh because critics don't
always see eye to eye and though film
can still garner shining reviews from
credible sources that doesn't mean it's
so fresh and so clean any film that
earns a tomato meter score of 60 or
higher can freely enter the fresh club
anything below that and you can head
next door where club ryan will gladly
take you in fun fact i'm actually
president of the rotten films fan club i
happen to really like rotten films i
mean just look at the score for space
jam or night at the roxbury and you'll
get a really good idea of who i am but
let's talk about the movies that came
really close but just didn't make the
cut and why these are our selections for
the rotten tomatoes almost fresh club
taken
who left that gate open
out of here
[Applause]
[Applause]
kicking off the french action thriller
taken directed by pierre morell and
written by luke fason and robert mark
cayman lehman neeson plays brian mills a
former cia operative who desperately
tries to reconnect with his daughter kim
kim was abducted in paris shortly after
arriving and now brian has four days to
rescue her before the unthinkable
happens in addition to neeson the film
stars maggie grace leland oser katie
cassidy and john grise though this
became a landmark role for neeson it was
actually jeff bridges who was originally
cast as brian mills but the dude didn't
abide and just before shooting began
bridges dropped out nissan happened to
be looking for a more physically
challenging role at the time and he
eagerly accepted the part though he
didn't expect this movie to be such a
career changer for him boy was he wrong
cause taken grossed over 226 million on
a budget of 25 million and spawned a
franchise that consists of two follow-up
sequels and a television series
are a very particular set of skills
skills i have acquired over a very long
career
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you
if you let my daughter go now that'll be
the end of it
i will not look for you
i will not pursue you
but if you don't
i will look for you
i will find you
and i will kill you
so why the almost fresh score well
critics like peter travers from rolling
stone wrote that the film was quote fun
for about 15 minutes seeing neeson do
james bond as a daddy dangerous but the
surprise wears off quickly and time
magazine wrote that taken has nothing
more on its mind than dozens of bad guys
getting beat up and another one turned
into instant roadkill but hey others did
praise the film writing that it's a
pedal to the metal actioner and calling
brian mills an efficient hero after the
film was released jeff bridges admitted
that neeson was a way better fit for the
role so correction the dude does in fact
abide die hard with a vengeance
wow
die hard with a vengeance is an action
thriller directed by john mctiernan the
man behind predator and the hunt for red
october it's the third film in the die
hard series featuring characters created
by rodrik thorpe for his 1979 novel
nothing lasts forever now bruce willis
returns as detective john mcclane only
now he's a divorced alcoholic recently
fired due to his reckless behavior and
bad attitude when a cryptic terrorist
takes new york city hostage in a lethal
game of simon says mclean is called back
in action that's because the terrorist
played by jeremy irons refuses to speak
with anyone other than mclean mclean
teams up with a street savvy electrician
named zeus played by samuel l jackson
and the two work together to halt the
murderous plot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
screenwriter jonathan hensley had
originally written a spec script
entitled simon says with young action
star brandon lee in mind warner brothers
then bought that script with the
intention of making it the fourth lethal
weapon movie but instead it was retooled
as another mclean adventure watching
this film you can see similarities in
the love-hate banter between mclean and
zeus and murton riggs and lethal weapon
die hard with a vengeance became the
highest grossing film of the year and
gained a cult following but it did
receive a mixed critical response many
praised jackson's performance with some
writing that he was almost as good as he
was in pulp fiction and we all know he
was pretty damn good in pulp fiction but
others felt that the film as a whole
didn't compete with the original die
hard and considered it quote subpar
still this film contains some of the
best action sequences ever and that's
why we fell in love with die hard in the
first place the hobbit the battle of the
five armies
my children
where are my children i saw them
new zealand director peter jackson has
masterfully brought j.r.r tolkien's epic
fantasy novels to life his adaptation of
the hobbit consists of three films the
last of which is the battle of the five
armies it stars martin freeman ian
mckellen richard armitage evangeline
lilly luke evans lee pace benedict
cumberbatch cate blanchett and so many
others i mean i could take up an entire
episode listing all the incredible
talent in this film but don't worry i
won't waste your precious or my precious
time but this installment follows thorin
oakenshield who has recently reclaimed
erenborg aka the lonely mountain from
the dragon smog thorin is blinded by
greed and sacrifices friendship and
honor in his search for the arkenstone a
powerful gem considered to be a divine
symbol for the king brave hobbit bilbo
baggins tries to reason with thorin as
sauron and an army of orcs attack the
lonely mountain
[Music]
[Music]
now the fate of middle earth hangs in
the balance of the elves dwarves and men
who must learn to work together or all
die the battle of the five armies
grossed over
962 million worldwide making it the
second highest grossing film of the year
behind transformers age of extinction it
was also nominated for best sound
editing at the 87th academy awards so
why the not so epic tomato meter score
well critics from the new york post
wrote that quote it's adequately
visionary routinely spectacular and
breathes fire yet somehow feels room
temperature and rolling stone called out
jackson for quote sadly saving the worst
for last but hey it was a victory after
all i suppose
pitch black
are you saying you'd cut me loose
i'm thinking you could have died in a
crash
my recommendation to me
don't take the chance that i'll get [ __ ]
happy when you
that's what i would do to you
[Music]
pitch black is a sci-fi horror directed
by david tui who also co-wrote the
script along with ken and jim wheat set
500 years in the future it is the story
of a dangerous criminal named richard
riddick who is being transported to
prison on a spacecraft when the ship
crashes on an unexplored planet the
survivors soon discover that said planet
will be entering a state of eclipse
which is bound to bring out some deadly
nocturnal creatures now riddick might be
the one to lead the survivors off this
planet if they can learn to trust him
vin diesel stars in this and additional
cast members include radha mitchell
keith david and cole hauser brotherly
duo ken and jim we had worked on horror
sequels like nightmare on elm street 4
the dream master and the fly 2.
ah
their script for pitch black was
originally called nightfall which was
mostly the same you know spaceship
crashes on an alien planet dark eclipse
brings monsters etc but in the initial
drafts the convict was a woman tui had
done some early work on what would
become alien 3 and he wanted to get this
movie as far away from copycat land as
possible which is why he opted for a
male lead and spent a lot of time
refining the character arcs this film
gained a cult following and spawned two
sequels the chronicles of riddick
released in 2004 and riddick released in
2013. though it became a sleeper hit
many considered the film cliche and
commented on its lack of actual horror
despite the genre deep blue sea
[Music]
america's shark obsession only seems to
be growing stronger partially ignited by
the classic jaws and the discovery
channel shark week which fun fact is the
longest run running cable television
program event in history one thing we
can count on if there's a shark involved
people will watch it and the 1999 sci-fi
horror deep blue sea was no exception to
that rule the film was directed by renny
harlan whose other action-forward
features include die hard 2 and cliff
hanger set on an island research
facility dr susan mcallister is focused
on harvesting the brain tissue of dna
altered mako sharks as a possible cure
for alzheimer's disease naturally things
soon go awry i mean who would have
imagined that sharks don't make for
docile test subjects these highly
intelligent makos outnumber their human
captors and mcallister and her team must
fight to survive while also preventing
said sharks from escaping to the ocean
and breeding
[Music]
all right people
let's move
now
come on you can't help come on
i mean this has to be the most
ridiculous premise for a shark movie
ever wait what's that there's a six film
series about a water spout lifting
sharks out of the ocean and placing them
in suburbs to terrorize people i stand
corrected deep blue sea story actually
has a pretty disturbing origin when
screenwriter duncan kennedy was a child
he actually witnessed a dead shark
attack victim on a beach in australia
this encounter led to recurring
nightmares in which kennedy was quote
being chased in chess deep flooded
hallways where he could barely move by
sharks that were always one step ahead
of him i mean if that doesn't sound
horrifying i don't know what is reviews
were mixed with the new yorker calling
it scary absurd and inessential and
empire magazine writing that it's about
giant sharks eating people and that's
exactly what you get if nothing else
though check out ll cool j's music video
for the theme song deepest bluest
spoiler alert he morphs into a shark you
can thank me later
a night's tale
[Music]
a knight's tale is an adventure rom-com
written directed and co-produced by
brian hegeland in his breakout role
heath ledger plays the peasant-born
william thatcher who begins a quest to
change his fate and in the process when
the heart of an exceedingly fair maiden
with a little help from his friends
william faces the ultimate test of
medieval gallantry tournament jousting
and discovers that he might just have
the medal to become a legend now this
film isn't so easily categorized on the
one hand it's a period piece on the
other hand it's a rock musical mixed
with historical fiction and splashes of
a sports epic pegaland was calculated in
his genre bending and his time jumping
the writer director admitted that in
1370 when the film is set it really
would have been men in tights but his
premise for this film was no matter what
century you're in the 70s are always the
70s i mean this explains the david bowie
and john lennon references to be of
humble origins
but my personal historians have
discovered
that he is descendant from an ancient
royal line
this is my word
and as such is beyond contestation
production shot on location in prague
and believe it or not the jousting in
this film is real after several failed
attempts to use tricky camera angles and
cgi hegelin decided to have his stunt
people actually joust which adds
authenticity and shock value to the
action sequences but don't worry the
lances were blunted and the actors had
padding though a knight's tale failed to
make it to the land of the fresh it did
gain a cult following and is largely
responsible for making heath ledger the
star that we love and miss so dearly
paranormal activity 2.
paranormal activity 2 is a prequel set
two months before the first film in the
franchise we follow the raise a family
who just moved into their new home in
southern california now it's a lovely
place there's just one itsy bitsy little
problem it is haunted as hell after
coming home one day to find things in
complete disarray with no signs of horse
entry or robbery the rays decide to
install a video surveillance camera to
catch the perpetrators but nothing could
prepare them for what happens next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after the gargantuan success of writer
director orrin pelley's first paranormal
activity paramount wasted no time in
getting a sequel made for this follow-up
kelly took on the role of producer and
todd williams was actually hired to
direct the screenplay written by michael
r perry christopher landon and tom pabst
it is common knowledge that the first
sequel can make or break a franchise so
the pressure was on for this one to be a
hit and commercially i'd say mission
accomplished paranormal activity 2 broke
the record for the biggest midnight
gross for an r rated film and had the
biggest opening of any horror movie in
history it placed number one at the box
office on its opening day and on a
shoestring budget of three million
dollars ended up grossing almost
180 million dollars but the curse of the
house of rey seemed to carry on over to
the critics and many felt that it was
inferior to the first film dr seuss's
the grinch
oh
thanks mister
hi
you're a mean one mister
[Music]
based on the 1957 book how the grinch
stole christmas dr seuss is a grinch is
a computer animated family comedy
produced by illumination their second dr
seuss adaptation following the lorax we
journey to the fantastical town of
whoville where the grinch and his loyal
dog max live their solitary existence
inside a cave on mount crumpet now we
all know mr grinch's main source of
aggravation is christmas so as the
holiday approaches he hatches a scheme
to pose as santa claus and silence the
who's holiday cheer once and for all
[Music]
we're doing it next we are doing it we
will not be
stopped the film features the voice
talents of benedict cumberbatch rashida
jones keenan thompson angela lansbury
and farrell williams who also serves as
the narrator the grinch became the
highest grossing christmas film of all
time finally surpassing home alone which
still remains in second place over 30
years after its initial release but
despite leaving an indelible mark in the
pantheon of holiday classics the
grinch's critical reception wasn't so
cheery peter travers playfully wrote
you're a mediocre one mr grinch and
moviefreak.com claimed that quote it's
so shockingly bland so immediately
forgettable so pedestrian in its
plotting that they found watching it to
be fairly laborious i mean hey guys
where's your christmas spirit oh wait
screen rant said that the grinch is
holiday fun for the whole family
adapting a classic story with a new
twist that makes for an altogether
compelling movie experience not bad but
still this one remains as rotten as
grinch himself the rugrats movie
nickelodeon's celebrated series rugrats
was adapted into a feature-length film
entitled the rugrats movie released in
1998 the animated comedy finds tommy
pickles trying to return his baby
brother to the hospital after being
warned by his mean-spirited friend
angelica that once his new sibling is
born his parents won't care about him
anymore i mean really angelica you're
saying these awful things to a toddler
while on the mission tommy and his
friends lose their way in the woods and
run into a pack of wild monkeys who have
recently escaped the circus tommy and
his friends begin to think that maybe
things at home weren't so bad after all
the movie features the voices of eg
daily tara strong christine kavanaugh
kath soucy cheryl chase and charlie
adler along with guest stars david spade
whoopi goldberg margaret cho buster
rhymes and tim curry
babies
[Music]
plans to make a rugrats feature were in
the works almost as soon as the series
first aired back in the early 90s but
due to production and distribution
obstacles it wasn't until 1995 that
production actually began for this film
it was well worth the wait because the
rugrats movie opened at number one and
became the first non-disney film to
gross over 100 million in the united
states it also spawned two sequels one
released in 2000 and another in 2003 but
as we've learned being popular doesn't
make you fresh and the critical
reception was mediocre roger ebert
disliked the film but admitted that he
might have liked it if he were a kid i'm
confused though was it unclear that
rugrats is in fact a kid's movie
venom let there be carnage i need human
brains to survive uh-uh now pick up some
chickens man let's go
[Music]
last up is venom let there be carnage a
superhero action film directed by andy
circus and written by kelly marcel it is
the second film in the sony spider-man
universe and the sequel to 2018's venom
we follow eddie brock who is still
struggling to coexist with his
shape-shifting extraterrestrial
counterpart and when deranged serial
killer cletus cassidy also becomes a
host to an alien symbiote known as
carnage brock and venom must put aside
their differences to stop his reign of
terror tom hardy is venom and additional
cast members include michelle williams
naomi harris reed scott steven graham
and woody harrelson and for those of you
unfamiliar with andy circus he is a
master in the art of motion capture
acting he actually portrayed caesar in
the planet of the apes reboot franchise
and played supreme leader snoke in the
star wars sequel film his unique
experience and skill set made him an
obvious choice to direct let there be
carnage as the film relies really
heavily on cgi and motion capture
technology he had also previously
directed the film's breathe and mowgli
the legend of the jungle so this was not
his first rodeo let there be carnage was
a commercial success becoming the
seventh highest grossing film of 2021
but critically it didn't redeem the poor
reception of the first venom film death
to you father no
not you father
you
father oh sh
this is much worse than i thought that
is a red one
red one we should leave immediately
honey we'll get over it we never liked
her anyway so
let's go now congratulations to the
happy couple we
are leaving though the london evening
standard labeled it intoxicating and vox
called it a superhero movie that
understands how scary the world can be
empire magazine wrote that for all the
talented people involved let there be
carnage still has a whiff of a turd in
the wind ew sounds rotten and that's
because it is and there you have it our
selections for the rotten tomatoes
almost fresh club i am nas perez thank
you so much for watching and remember
just because it's rotten doesn't mean it
isn't rocking
bye
[Music]
you